thank you so much I am thrilled to be
here and to participate in this
important commencement of this great
University this great College because I
too am a graduate of a woman's college
and I think it's the best the best
investment that I and my parents ever
made it is my honor therefore to join
you in celebrating and I want to
congratulate all of the students
speakers who I thought did an excellent
job in expressing the feelings and the
aspirations of this class I am honored
to be in the company of my fellow
honorees each of whom has so well
deserved this medal and I want to
congratulate your president on a
brilliant first year as the head of
Barnard and I want to thank another
woman who has had not only an impact on
this College over the years but on me
personally and that is the wise and
wonderful Anna Quindlen her writing has
helped to shape the public debate on
issues affecting women families and all
Americans her final column which ran
this week was about making way for the
next generation and as always Anna's
message rings true especially as we
honor this class of graduates we are
meeting at a time of unprecedented
opportunity and achievement for women as
you've already heard women are serving
at the highest levels of governments
here in the United States and around the
world in business and academia and the
professions we are presiding over
companies and colleges
philanthropies and laboratories and
breaking new ground as artists and
activists and athletes we're even seeing
gender barriers broken at the racetrack
I don't know about you but I personally
felt vindicated when Rachel Alexandra
won the Preakness went where no filly
has gone in 85 years up against eight
stallions I can't say I exactly
identified with her but I was very
pleased that she brought home the
black-eyed Susans
today we are celebrating a class and an
institution that is always ahead of the
rest you know this is a milestone of 120
years of educating women a furthering
scholarship and serving the city of New
York and the people of the world now it
is easy to forget that when Barnard
first opened its doors in 1889 higher
education for women was viewed with
great suspicion and many women and men
labored for years to make this college
possible and even after Barnard finally
came into being they had to spend even
more years convincing the world there
was nothing to fear about women's
education and that the work being done
here was truly a good thing now rumors
still flew for decades about exactly
what went on at Barnard finally in 1912
the New York Times decided to
investigate and it published a long
interview with the great Dean of Barnard
Virginia Gildersleeve
which ran under the headline I quote
college girls are healthy normal
American girls
I'm sure that the readers of The Times
found that reassuring and a few decades
later the editors and reporters did as
well in fact dr. Gildersleeve made a
persuasive case for why Barnard and
women's education in general is actually
crucial to our society she talked about
how the college broaden its students
expose them to new ideas and
perspectives introduce them to people
from different backgrounds
she said that was a force not only for
good for these women but for their
communities as she put it we do not
teach manners but we do teach manner
poise interest tolerance and
understanding these are the things that
college life teaches now the context may
have been different then but the vision
behind it is much the same just as those
early Barnard students were being
prepared for a world beyond their
personal horizons you have been prepared
for global citizenship in the
interconnected world of the 21st century
you are coming of age at a time of
unprecedented challenges war and
terrorism climate change and economic
recession extreme poverty and extreme
ideologies the proliferation of disease
and nuclear weapons these challenges
transcend borders and oceans politics
and ideology and they affect us all but
the same interconnectedness that
amplifies these global challenges also
makes it possible for us to solve them
and for you to help lead us to the
solutions when I graduated from college
diplomacy was mainly conducted by
experts behind closed doors they were
primarily men and very little of what
they did was really visible
the rest of us today diplomacy is no
longer confined to the State Department
or to diplomats in pinstripe suits in
this global age we are engaging in 21st
century statecraft and it is carried out
beyond the halls of government in
Barrios and rural villages in corporate
boardrooms and halls of government as
well but also church basements hospitals
union halls civic and cultural centers
and even in the dorms and classrooms of
colleges like this the diplomacy of this
age is fueled by personal engagement and
interpersonal connections and that's
where all of you come in with new tools
and technologies and with the first-rate
education you've received you now have
the capacity to influence events in ways
that no previous generation ever has but
of course with that opportunity does
come responsibilities because this new
era of diplomacy requires a new
commitment to global service a
continuing effort from each of you to
help us tackle the most urgent problems
we face just as we have special envoys
for climate change or peace in the
Middle East so too much must each of you
be a special envoy of your ideals use
your skill and talent with these new
tools to help shape and reshape the
future I want to talk about a particular
area where I think you can you should
and you must make a difference it's
important to me personally and it's
especially important in my new job and
that is the plight of women and girls
around the world as women with strong
voices and strong values you are in a
unique position to support women
worldwide who don't have the resources
you do but whose lives and dreams are
just as worth
as yours and mine I have concluded after
traveling many miles and visiting many
places in the last decades that talent
is universally distributed but
opportunity is not the futures of these
women and girls will affect yours and
mine and therefore it is not only the
right thing to do but also the smart
thing although not always acknowledged
by governments businesses or society
over all women and girls bear a
disproportionate burden of most of the
problems we face today in the midst of
this global economic crisis women who
are already the majority of the world's
poor are driven deeper into poverty in
places where food is scarce women and
girls are often the last to eat and eat
the least in regions torn apart by war
and conflict women are more likely to be
refugees or targets of sexual violence
and just yesterday in a column by one of
the former honorees by Barnard Nick
Kristof we learned that one of the most
dangerous places for women to be in the
world is in childbirth meanwhile in some
places girls are deliberately denied in
education even subjected to abuse and
violence if they attempt to go to school
as we have seen too frequently over the
last weeks in Afghanistan now let me be
clear women around the world League
varied lives and for many women religion
and culture are important sources of
spiritual growth identity and pride but
the retrograde regimes around the world
that pervert religion and culture to
perpetuate violence and stand in the way
of freedom and make women their primary
targets are a different story
the subjugation of women the denial of
their rights as human beings is not an
expression of religion or of God's will
it is a betrayal of both
and women's progress is more than a
matter of morality it is a political
economic social and security imperative
for the United States and for every
nation represented in this graduating
class if you want to know how stable
healthy and democratic a country is look
at its women look at its girls when I
went to the United Nations conference on
women in Beijing back in 1995 I made the
point which seemed to me to be pretty
obvious that women's rights are human
rights and human rights are women's
rights well I was gratified but somewhat
shocked at the reaction it produced and
as I have traveled in the years since I
have met so many women who took such
heart from that simple statement they
understood deep in their gut that they
had to be supported that their struggles
had to be acknowledged for them to gain
a foothold to gain that space whether be
on the subway or back in a marketplace
there are signs of hope and progress
just this weekend the people of Kuwait
elected women to their Parliament for
the first time in history this did not
come easily or quickly starting in the
1990s I supported the women who were
brave enough to stand up and say women
should be able to serve it took a long
struggle but the election of four women
this Saturday is a major step forward
for Kuwait the region and I would argue
the world and yet the marginalization of
women and girls goes on it is one of
humankind's oldest problems but what is
different today
is that we have 21st century tools to
combat it
think of the women in eastern Congo a
place of such violence despair and chaos
who are using radio airwaves to warn
other women and to send out the message
to the world how this war these militias
are destroying their communities think
of the women in Afghanistan who against
such great odds started a single school
that has grown into a network of schools
or the domestic violence center they
began which now serves thousands of
women and girls or the women in Cambodia
who were sold into sex slavery as girls
but who escaped and are now organizing
raids of brothels throughout Southeast
Asia to rescue girls and give them a
chance at an education and a new life
some months ago here in New York I had
the privilege of meeting a young girl
from Yemen
her name is Nujood Ali and she was nine
years old her family offered her
intermarriage with a much older man who
turned out to be violent and abusive at
10 years old desperate to escape her
circumstances she left her home and made
her way to the local courthouse where
she sat against a wall all day long
until she was finally noticed thankfully
by a woman lawyer named Shaddaa nasser
who asked this little girl what she was
doing there and the little girl said she
came to get a divorce and thanks to this
lawyer she did now in another time the
story of her individual courage and her
equally brave lawyer would not have been
covered in the news even in her own
country but now it is beamed worldwide
by satellites shared on blogs posted on
Twitter celebrated in gatherings today
women are finding their voices and
those voices are being heard far beyond
their own narrow circumstances and
here's what each of you can do you can
visit the website of a nonprofit called
Kiva ki va and sent a micro loan to an
entrepreneur like Blanca who wants to
expand her small grocery store in Peru
you can send children's books to a
library in Namibia by purchasing items
off an amazon.com wish list you can sit
in your dorm room or soon your new
apartment and use the web to plant trees
across Africa through Wangari Maathai x'
green belt movement and with these
social networking tools that you use
every day to tell people you've gone to
get a latte or you're gonna be running
late you can unite your friends through
Facebook to fight human trafficking or
child marriage like the two recent
college graduates in Colombia the
country who organized 14 million people
into the largest anti-terrorism
demonstration in history doing as much
damage to the FARC terrorist network in
a few weeks that had been done in years
of military action and you can organize
through Twitter like the undergraduates
at Northwestern who launched a global
fast to bring attention to Iran's
imprisonment of an American journalist
and we have two young women journalists
right now in prison in North Korea and
you can get busy on the Internet and let
the North Koreans know that we find that
absolutely unacceptable these new tools
are available for everyone they are
democratizing diplomacy so over the next
year we will be creating virtual student
Foreign Service internships to partner
American students with our embassies
abroad to conduct digital diplomacy and
you can learn more about this initiative
on the State Department website this is
an opportunity for all of us to ask
ourselves what can I do
I'm heading off to my first job or I may
be going to travel for a while or I have
some other ideas that I'm exploring but
no matter what you're doing you can be a
citizen activist and a citizen diplomat
you've already begun to make the
connections and partnerships that will
give you support throughout your lives
and therefore I invite you to forge
those connections beyond this class
you've learned here at Barnard that in
spite of our differences we are all
connected and we need to be looking for
ways to find inspiration from our daily
lives just a few weeks ago I read
president spars column in The Wall
Street Journal in which she bravely
attempted to write her own application
essay essay for Barnard described a
typical day in her life one that
involved coordinating her kids
carpooling
fixing dinner answering emails dealing
with a mischievous cat writing a speech
on what else women in leadership as I
read about the controlled chaos of your
president's life I thought this sure
sounds familiar and as I look out in the
audience today I see a lot of mothers
and grandmothers and fathers and
grandfathers and family members and
friends and I know that you two have had
these experiences but no matter how we
come to this commencement we leave
knowing that another class of
extraordinary young women who will have
the manner and the education to go and
not only pursue their own dreams but
help bring along others as well has
occurred within this remarkable
institution we all have an opportunity
today to do so much more than I even
dreamed possible when I sat where you
are sitting all those years ago as I was
listening to
ooh Sarah bez nobs address and how she
was talking about her mother I had to
smile because I often say that in my
next life I'm going to come back as my
daughter and I felt a remarkable kinship
with Sarah's mother and with other
mothers of my generation and those who
came before like my own mother who was
born before women could vote that no
matter how satisfying our lives have
been how we have put together pieces
that add up to a whole that is so
important to us and has given meaning to
this journey we are on we look at young
women and we think to ourselves this is
a future that women in the history of
the world have never been able to
imagine that you leave here empowered in
a way that women and girls have never
been before it's exciting but it's
daunting but I know you're up to it
serving the people of the world does not
have to be your life's calling but I
urge you to make it a part of your life
to include it in whatever you decide to
do as you start out on this adventure
you are certainly well prepared and I
wish for each and every one of you an
adventure that gives you the same sense
of meaning and purpose that you are
looking for and an understanding of how
much more you can do with the gifts you
have been given and to decide that you
too will try to be those special envoys
of the ideals that you believe in
Godspeed and congratulations